قائمة الدول الأوروبية التي تفرض
قيودًا على الوافدين من الصين
تتزايد ، كانت إيطاليا أول دولة في
الاتحاد الأوروبي تختبر جميع الركاب الذين يصلون
على متن رحلات جوية مباشرة من الصين
ووجدوا حالات إيجابية في كل
رحلة قادمة حتى الآن
تصر جورجيا مالوني رئيس الوزراء الإيطالي على ذلك
لن ينجح الإجراء الوقائي إلا إذا قامت
الدول الأخرى
بنفس الإجراء الذي قد لا يكون
فعالاً تمامًا إذا لم يتم اتخاذه على
المستوى الأوروبي لأننا نعلم أنه
يمكننا القيام بذلك للرحلات القادمة مباشرة
من الصين ولكن ليس على سبيل المثال من
أولئك الذين يصلون عبر محطات التوقف.  لذلك طلبت من
وزير الصحة سكيلاتشي الذي
تصرف على الفور بهذا المعنى بالكتابة إلى
المفوض الأوروبي المسؤول عن
هذا الأمر وطلب من الاتحاد
الأوروبي اتخاذ تدابير بهذا المعنى ،
وقد انضمت إسبانيا الآن إلى إيطاليا في طلب
الاختبارات السلبية للركاب القادمين
من الصين ، لكنهم سيفعلون ذلك.  خذ أيضًا دليلًا
على التطعيمات
على المستوى الأوروبي الذي ندفع من
أجله  الحاجة إلى مراجعة
التوصية لطلب
شهادة تطعيم رقمية سرية أو
ما يعادلها للمسافرين من الصين
كأفضل ضمان أمني لجميع
السلطات تشعر بالقلق من أن الصين
ليست شفافة بشأن مدى سوء الأمور
بالفعل أو إذا كان هناك جديد
المتغيرات الناشئة
في إيطاليا ، تظهر عينات من الاختبارات الإيجابية
من الركاب من الصين أن
Omicron فقط حتى الآن ، لكنهم لا يخططون لذلك
اتركوا حذرهم في أي وقت قريبًا ، سيظل
توجيه الاختبار في المطارات مثل
هذا بالقرب من روما ساري المفعول حتى
31 يناير على الأقل
باربي لاتيه نادو سي إن إن ليوناردو دافنشي
مطار فيوميتشينو إيطاليا